[Musique]
à
nous avons eu besoin chaque jour de 10
mille donc pour répondre aux besoins des
malades
les produits sanguins compte une durée
de conservation limitée 42 jours pour
les globules rouges et sept jours pour
les plaquettes dont nous avons tous les
jours besoin de prélever des donneurs
[Musique]
au prendre rendez-vous en passant par le
site internet pour trouver les lieux le
collègue dé prendre rendez vous ou bien
appelant directement les six une pièce
d'identité sera demandée à l'accueil de
la collecte pour donner son sang il faut
être en bonne santé il faut avoir entre
18 et 70 ans et peser au moins 50 kilos
après une infection à corona virus il
faut attendre 28 jours pour pouvoir
donner
[Musique]